we've got gorgeous skies out there this
morning this is a nice fall day we've
got a lot of sunshine coming all day
long
clear skies overnight means cooler
temperatures this morning we're down to
the low 40s the seven hills
sunrise mountain at 40 look at nellis at
37 and
it's below freezing up there at kyle
canyon 36 in
41 in red rock and 37 in boulder city so
definitely some cooler numbers this
morning than what we had yesterday
we're going to get some ferocious winds
up in western and northern nevada
even down into central nevada all as
this system pushes in to the pacific
northwest look at the rain and the snow
that won't reach us but we will get some
winds in the western mojave desert
by tonight and we'll get some winds in
our local mountains today too so be
careful
and post tropical aida that means that
it's no longer a tropical storm it's a
low pressure system
pushing away from the east coast and
that's good news for the folks who are
caught in all that flooding in the
carolinas
also nasa launching that spacex rocket
the falcon 9
carrying four astronauts up to the
international space station that
launches tomorrow night hopefully
the forecast stays good it looks good
today in florida 47 up on the mountain
and remember that revel marathon is
going on
i believe today and tomorrow nate can
tell you more about that but please
watch out for the runners up there 47
degrees
for the high on the mountain 69 in the
valley today 68's normal so we finally
get back to normal
enjoy a beautiful fall weekend and then
later next week
check out the warmth upper 70s to near
80 degrees
periods of clouds from time to time
warmer mornings
in the 50s nate up on the mountain it's
going to be a little dicey but i'm sure
they'll have
coned off areas for those runners